hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of science
and technology i'm happy to try and
answer whatever i can about that topic
and i see there are all kinds of
questions saved up here
and that have come in on the submission
form that we have
it's a question from jack here
do you think we'll ever get to the stage
of having flying cars is there any
historical evidence
that's a fun question you know i
remember
seeing issues of popular mechanics
magazine
from
50 years ago maybe
that are about flying cars
and i think
you know back from
now it must be more than 50 years ago it
must be the 1950s actually
uh i'm losing track of time 70 years ago
um
i think as soon as people had cars
which they've had since basically the
beginning of the you know beginning of
the 1900s ish
and airplanes which came in at more or
less the same time i mean you know
bicycles
airplanes cars
surprisingly
a small period of time that those
appeared uh in the late 1800s the
beginning of 1900s
and uh you know when people sort of say
the wright brothers were
you know bicycle mechanics oh you know
it was just a bicycle mechanic that made
the airplane it's like well bicycle
mechanics were
the leading edge so to speak and it sort
of reminds me of the of the thing where
people say oh albert einstein was you
know just a patent clerk at the patent
office in burn in switzerland you know
he kind of uh
he'd fallen off the track so to speak
well actually you know the patent office
in burn was kind of the silicon valley
of its time it was the place where kind
of leading edge of things
in technology in particular were going
on in that particular case it was uh
refrigerators and i think einstein even
had a patent or two on refrigerators
himself
um but that was uh that was kind of the
the high-tech leading edge of its time
the kind of the i don't know what it is
the
the what was machine learning a few
years ago is now probably blockchain of
its time so to speak with refrigerators
and the burn patent office was the thing
so in any case i think that this concept
of flying cars
is probably
dates i bet there are things from the
1920s talking about flying cars because
once you have planes and you have cars
you think about uh you know making uh
sort of the the personal plane kind of
thing
you know another thing that is notable
uh so so why aren't there flying cars
now and what else come on say about that
another thing it's notable if you look
at small planes like i know cessna
airplanes i don't think the designs have
changed since the 1950s probably um you
know there's new avionics and things
like that but it's a basic you know it's
the plane with its wings high up and
it's you know the same structure
and i mean maybe there have been tweak
updates but i think the main
sort of thing
about
a
uh you know a single propeller small
plane really hasn't changed in a long
time
um and i think
that's a
so you know why didn't that turn into
the flying car
um
i think
there's a related question which is why
did helicopters not become more popular
i mean it was the case that
in i remember
oh when was this back in the 70s and
early 80s
there were some companies i remember
digital equipment corporation for
example which had a bunch of
little offices dotted around the new
england area
they were very big on helicoptering
people from one place to another but
that was a very rare case
but somehow helicopters didn't catch on
in the way that people thought
in the 1950s for example that they might
uh my impression is the the couple of
reasons for that
one is they're kind of hard to fly
and another is they're kind of hard to
maintain
and
the
the the sort of their finicky creatures
and so it just wasn't something that
could easily be consumerized so to speak
and the hard-to-fly part is also
important because by the time you're
spending you know
uh you know there's a
you might argue an interesting question
you know for cars for example
uh cars
were presumably
sort of one eased into them being not
totally easy to drive i mean they've
gotten easier to drive as automatic
transmission automatic gear changes and
so on came in but i suppose that the
early cars
probably you know before there were
driving licenses and all those kinds of
things the early cars they weren't going
terribly fast
and the kind of the mechanism for oh you
steer it it's kind of like you know
nobody expected
people expected a small amount of
difficulty in learning to use them like
riding a bicycle but not a huge amount
of difficulty planes are a different
story and helicopters yet another level
of of story um and i think that's you
know you you don't expect
to you know it's such a such a difficult
thing because because one would think
i mean the truth is if you you know i
learned to fly little planes many many
years ago i haven't done it for a very
long time but you know fundamentally if
the plane is flying and somebody just
hands you the controls you know nothing
terrible is going to happen in the next
few minutes probably unless you do
something really silly but
if you are trying to land the plane for
example that takes some
level of skill
that
probably exceeds the level of stereo the
question is is it harder to learn to
parallel park or to learn to land a
plane and i think it's definitively
harder to learn to land a plane than to
learn to parallel park
so you know that that is probably a
reason why that wasn't a thing
now
uh on the helicopter story you might ask
you know the ubiquity of drones
in the last i don't know what is it five
six seven years or something
when did drones let's see must have been
ten years ago or something that the
first consumer
drones
um
started to come in when they were still
being called quadrocopters or
quadcopters and so on
and
the the thing that had limited that
there were two things one was battery
technology could you actually you know
power the motors and have the thing lift
itself up and fly for a reasonable time
that was thing number one and thing
number two was could you have the flight
controller um that is doing the the
feedback control loop to keep the thing
you know flying level and so on could
you could you operate that could could
the computers that were needed to run
the flight controller in real time and
so on be able to be powered from the
batteries be able to be small small
enough etc and i think those things
converged maybe 10-ish years ago people
had imagined the idea of quadcopters
back or in the 1950s for sure but it was
super difficult like a human trying to
fly the thing it just doesn't work you
just can't control it quickly enough and
so on and the thing goes unstable and my
impression is that's the you know
helicopters are just are controllable by
people but it's difficult quadcopters
were not controllable by people and it
took sort of electronic automatic
control to be able to do that and that's
something where sort of the things of
computers and batteries and so on
converge roughly 10 years ago
and
so now the question is well what about a
flying car
um
i think that's a partly a question of
battery technology partly a question of
uh other kinds of things i mean i've
seen
well let's see i've seen several
demos or pseudo demos of flying cars
um i remember one at consumer
electronics show maybe five years ago or
something now
one at an event that i was at um just
recently
where i have to admit in neither case
that i actually see the thing take off
um it was claimed to take off but it
didn't actually do it
um so i can't say oh and actually now
that i think about it there's another
example even
uh
which i which i saw kind of privately so
to speak um of something where they're
sort of samples but they're not quite
the right scale they're not quite i
think the technology curves for
batteries and other things haven't quite
reached the point where you can do it
and i think about it i've also seen a
bunch of business plans for these things
um
the
you know my impression is flying cars
are coming
now
you know the other point is how do you
believe in
sort of the automatic pilot for the
flying car because you're not going to
have
the i think it is unlikely that the
typical consumer is going to seriously
learn to fly now maybe that's not
correct
maybe
maybe
that with enough kind of intermediate
uh automated control
that
your average consumer could perfectly
well learn to fly and the parts that are
difficult and sensitive about landing
and things like that that that could be
automated and that the human is just
giving the overall instructions i mean
it you know you could say
that when you drive a car like for
somebody like me that learned to drive a
stick shift car um because that was sort
of all there was
in in the you know sort of mid-1970s in
england or something um
that was that's oh that's kind of
difficult
and uh uh you know you have to learn
that extra set of things nowadays uh
people in a country like us at least
where where automatic transmission cars
are ubiquitous people just don't learn
that stuff you know how do you start a
a
a stick shift car on a hill well it's
kind of tricky because you know you you
press the clutch the thing this
you know disconnects its its um its
drive system or whatever and unless you
have your foot on the uh on the gas to
push it forward a bit or on the on the
um on the brake and so on you know the
thing will start rolling backwards gosh
i didn't i might have almost forgotten
how to do this i think well yeah you you
have to balance it so that you put the
thing in gear and you're pressing the
gas enough to keep the thing from
rolling backwards and and i'm you know i
learned to do that some ridiculous
number of years ago and uh every so
often i have to do it again but
you know that's i would say that that's
again pretty easy compared to landing a
plane uh for you know current kinds of
planes but by the time you've automated
some pieces of land in the plane maybe
it becomes comparable and maybe it's
something that consumers can do so long
as they trust the automation chain
that's doing the landing but i think
most of the business plans i've seen
involve a couple of different kinds one
is
there is a taxi driver so to speak who's
who's
flying the air taxi for you or the other
is just get in the thing and it will
take you where you're supposed to go and
that's the same thing you know you see
these demos at someone very recently
actually the demos of self-driving taxis
where basically it's you know you get in
it and um it's there's no person driving
it and it just takes you where you're
supposed to go
um
the uh
um
it's um
i think uh
uh
so i mean i
my impression is that flying cars
finally after probably nearly 100 years
of gestation might be about to arrive
now
it's an interesting question what effect
that will have for example you know the
ubiquity of cars is what drove the
development of suburbs in in uh you know
post world war ii period and people have
been saying for for years oh there are
going to be ex-serbs and everybody's
going to live in view of a you know
right now near a mountain even though
that's far away from the big cities and
so on and uh you know perhaps
the advent of ubiquitous flying cars
will mean that there's you know there's
again a shift in population um in
in the way that there was with cars and
suburbs and so on i don't know um but
yeah i think
i mean i might be wrong but i think i
think one is finally at this point i
mean it's always interesting these
technology curves of things like you
know fax machines for example they were
100 years in gestation people had
telegraphs that i think even gauss had a
telegraph that was hooked up to some
kind of plotter type thing that could
act like a fax machine and that was uh
you know solidly sometime in the what
1870s maybe i don't know
um
and it took until
you know fax machines actually came
really on the scene
in what the late 1970s they've gone away
now um but that was a consequence of
electronics and uh you know what did it
take to be able to do the compression
and decompress it and so on and it was
sort of an electronics curve i guess
maybe together with a phone line quality
card i'm not sure
but you know another one that's it's
really a classic of this kind is virtual
reality where you know i saw the first
demos of that in
when was it in the um late 80s
uh
and you know it's starting to finally
really be here now
but it's still been a thing where people
sort of said is it coming is it coming
you know i know in our company we've
done a bunch of things with vr and uh
i was trying to push about three or four
years ago i was trying to push again for
us to do things with vr and some of the
people in the company a long time said
that's just what you said in the early
1990s trying to persuade us to do vr
work then we did some then and look what
a bust that was
so you know it's it's funny how these
things you know eventually all the
pieces converge uh
same with electric cars as another
example where you know that's a battery
technology thing at least that's my
impression um and uh you know things
gradually converge to the point where
something becomes possible
that's one of the ways that sort of
technology arrives as there's been a
program of the technology perhaps for
for many decades and then finally things
get to the point where where it actually
makes sense
i mean i i do think that
the
uh
this question of i mean the economics of
of self-driving of of of flying cars
is is a you know there are all kinds of
issues i mean to mention transportation
kinds of issues like for example when
dean caiman developed the segway you
know which was i guess something that
was a sort of a spin-off of wheelchair
technology that his companies had
developed for for various other other
kinds of uh of companies and so on but
you know people were originally oh
segways are going to take over the world
so to speak and everybody's going to be
you know
tooling around on one of these um i
don't know what the generic term for
that is a um
i
don't know a self-propulsion platform or
something i don't know what the right
right term is for for a generic for for
those things but you know why didn't
that take off
i'm not sure maybe they were a bit
expensive maybe they were a bit big
um
maybe the use cases weren't there i'm
not sure maybe people
maybe wanted to walk i don't know i
think there are plenty of cases where
people would think oh that was a
worthwhile thing to to be able to go a
bit faster or a bit less effort and so
on
you know i don't know maybe it was maybe
it was details or maybe it was that
there was some fundamental technology
thing
that wasn't at the right price at that
time and maybe in another five or ten
years
something some successor of that will
will become super popular
um i mean i think the um
uh gosh what was it called the um i got
one of these the the uh
oh
i think it's called
nine five nine i forget what it is it's
a it's a thing that you stand on that's
kind of like a a segue but it doesn't
have a thing you have to hold it's that
it's a um just um
oh i don't know what it's called uh
uh there was a a kind of a craze for
these things for a while
um
let's see current from doodam here even
now with traction control antelope
braking systems automatic crash
avoidance and the like driving cars as
automated smart safeguards nowadays
yeah i mean yeah it's interesting i mean
i i
i think
the basics of driving cars well things
like anti-lock brakes
you know people were still driving cars
around even when they were skidding on
ice
without anti-lock braking
because the basics were fairly easy if
you're flying a plane and you just can't
land
you know then even the basics aren't
okay you could probably drive a car
perfectly well without being able to
perfectly parallel park and so on
um
let's see there's a question from frost
here seems like many science discoveries
or inventions happen due to some mistake
or error that ultimately makes the
insider experiment work how prevalent is
that
i don't think it's as prevalent as one
thinks
because i think that most discoveries
you have to be primed to make that
discovery
it is a very
unusual person and situation and very
rare in history much rarer than the
history books would make you believe
that somebody notices something awry
notices something they didn't expect
and
says
uh
really they really really didn't expect
there was nowhere near what they
expected and they say aha now i've got
this whole giant theory
that's really rare
i mean i think
uh
you know i can tell even stories from my
own past
where things that i've discovered
i was
not quite primed for them and so it took
ages to really realize that that was a
thing
actually i mean i i think maybe i told
the story fairly recently because i've
sort of just figured out this particular
piece of personal history kind of
embarrassing because it's a something of
my own from 40 years ago
i was starting to look at cellular
automata these simple programs that um
just run on this line of black and white
cells and and you see
in many cases very complicated behavior
well i had come into that project
knowing
lots of stuff about mathematical physics
and i had assumed that these little tiny
programs i was studying that all this
very heavy machinery from mathematical
physics i'd just be able to mow these
things down and figure out how they
worked
didn't work that way i got a bunch of
other people mathematicians particularly
some physicists as well interested in
these things they too tried to figure
out can you figure stuff out about these
things they too failed to figure stuff
out using methods for mathematical
physics
but
the thing that i realized was
that
the very fact that it was hard to figure
things out was itself highly interesting
and it led to this idea of computational
irreducibility led to this whole new
kind of science eventually led to our
physics project it's had a giant chain
of things
spanning 40 years now that have emerged
from this
this thing that you might call it an
accidental discovery but it really
wasn't and it took a while now as i as i
mentioned this even to you guys i
realize there's another absolutely
critical piece of the story which i'm
sort of not joining the dots for
properly
which is the following that when i was
starting to study cellular automata and
these kinds of things there were two big
sort of tool sets that i had
one was from mathematical physics
and the other was from computational
language design because i had built in
1979 to 1981 i built a thing called snp
which was kind of a forerunner of
mathematical multilanguage and it was
a very kind of principled uh kind of
fundamentals of computation fundamentals
and mathematical logic uh symbolic
computation system
and so i had that experience and i also
knew
that
in you know i i knew about universal
computation i knew that pretty
viscerally so to speak by that time that
you could have sort of rules for
computation that would sort of give you
this sort of universal ability to to
compute whatever you want to compute so
as i think about it actually as i'm as
i'm sitting here right now i'm realizing
that even recently i hadn't joined the
dots properly on this history because
the fact that
i ended up sort of pivoting and
realizing the fact that mathematical
physics wasn't working means you should
look elsewhere where should you look
well you should look at something
computational which by the way i happen
to have just spent multiple years
studying and understanding rather deeply
so the fact that so you might say was
that an accidental discovery
uh
you know it was accidental you know for
example rule 30 the fact that i
discovered rule 30 when i did
and paid attention to it when i did that
was sort of accidental it had to do with
the fact that i was testing out some
laser printer and decided i should run
this particular thing and i didn't
really didn't really take it that
seriously at that point and i get this
picture and it's like i really should
take this seriously and you could say
that was kind of an accidental thing but
it was accidental after i've been primed
by you know four or five years of
thinking about related kinds of things
and i think
that's that's really you know
we are just not very good at
taking in something that we completely
don't expect for which we have no
conceptual framework and saying aha this
is what this all means
um you know i think you can go back and
look at
uh
you know many kinds of discoveries and
inventions and so on
and
there was some
uh you know you could you can always see
some kind of framework now you know i
don't know i i don't know all of these
histories i mean something like bucky
balls carbon 60 you know uh
things
uh the fact that those weren't
discovered gazillions of years earlier
than they were
again was a kind of people just weren't
looking for them it wasn't that and by
the time they were discovered they were
discovered because people have been
trying to construct you know very
elaborate caged carbon molecules and
things like this and then it's like well
let's go look for carbon 60 and then
it's oh they've got these experiments
like to look for them here we've got
methodology for testing out these things
that we were trying to construct
had somebody found that
back in the day so to speak that they
did some tests and they you know maybe
that could have happened but i think
that's really the exception not the rule
i think you know there are there are
endless examples where
people without a conceptual framework
they just didn't look for they didn't
think about things in the right way they
didn't look for the right things so i
kind of think this this accidental
discovery thing it's a great storybook
kind of
story i think it's usually not true
and my own observation from studying
kind of historical biography of
scientists and so on is even when the
storybooks basically say and then
somebody had this brilliant idea and did
this
it really didn't happen that way there
was usually a decade of kind of
conceptual development which yes didn't
actually get that particular one
you know
special thing that they had to notice
um but
it was kind of building a conceptual
framework that primed the person for to
be able to to pay attention to that
thing that was on it that was at least
locally unexpected i mean they're just
the huge numbers of examples of things
that were missed
because people didn't have the
frameworks um to to study them the
things that i've had had the pleasure of
discovering so to speak that that people
could have discovered decades even
centuries earlier if they'd had the
right conceptual framework in thinking
about what was going on i mean a very
typical example is this whole phenomenon
of computational irritability there are
many examples where for example simple
rules produce complicated behavior and
so on you see that in the in the
sequence of prime numbers for example
but
people weren't looking at that there was
endless work done by gauss and riemann
and all these kinds of people on what
regularities can you tease out of this
seeming randomness of the distribution
of primes
but their question was what regularities
can tease out
not
let's try and understand what the sort
of fundamental conceptual philosophical
foundation for that apparent randomness
is
so let's see
uh
let's see there's some questions here
okay it's a question here from dennis
about the history of automated theorem
proving
um
and then do i think that we're on the
cusp of an era when computers were
improving theorems and mathematicians
will interpret them
um the second answer is easier than the
first
well okay let me say the following thing
there's been a history of automated
theorem improving dates back to the
1950s
i can tell you a little bit about what i
know about that history
um
there's been
a
sort of well what is automated theorem
proven automatic they're improving is
you're given a collection collection of
axioms you know
p dot q equals q dot p
p dot q dot r equals blah blah blah and
then you're asked given a theorem
about ps and q's and dots and so on
prove that theorem and so you're going
to prove that theorem by showing that
just by making sort of substitutions
based on the axioms you can eventually
derive the theorem that you're asking
for
and
there were sort of subcases of that that
was studied
in
i'm trying to remember here
in the 1950s
uh
sort of a sub case that was was quite
popular
was uh to do with uh theorems in boolean
algebra theorems and logic and
particularly questions like
satisfiability
um
and uh
um
yeah and and finding
for example given a logic expression p
and q or r and not p and so on
find
values of p q and r that make that
expression true
it was in 1971
it was proved that that was sort of a
quintessential mp complete problem so in
principle we believe probably that
ultimately you can do no better than
sort of filling in
uh the uh the exponentially many
possible values to check whether any of
them work but in practice you can do a
lot better and um there was an algorithm
of davis putnam
uh
that's martin davis and hillary putnam
uh algorithm from the 1950s early very
early computers
um
that is the algorithm that is still
actually widely used for satisfiability
solving that was an early example of an
algorithm for that did
that would take a logic expression and
be able to answer that that was sort of
an early example if they're improving
there was
there were then
i the fundamental problem of theorem
proving is
the sort of in principle you have to try
lots of possibilities to figure out can
you find a path that says you apply this
axiom then that axiom you make this
lemma you apply that lemma you make out
use the other lemmas to make another
lemma you keep building this whole thing
and eventually you find this path
through this essentially network of of
uh of results to get to the theorem you
want uh if the people who've been
following some what i've been doing the
big project
of um
uh the beginning of this year was this
thing that's this giant document about
the physicalization of meta mathematics
and a lot of that is about
uh this kind of process of you apply
axioms you apply axioms again you keep
applying them you get this whole i was
what one can call it entailment cone of
all the different results that are
entailed by a particular an initial
result or initial set of axioms and then
theorem proving is about in this giant
network of things that are entailed if
you're searching for a particular
theorem see if you can find the path
through that giant graph that gets you
to that theorem in an efficient way
that's kind of the the goal of theorem
proving
and what has happened is
there's
a certain amount of kind of black magic
that goes on if can you find the path oh
did you go the wrong way is that path
going to go nowhere let's try and pull
you back to a path that goes somewhere
now there is a
a a kind of a a clever idea it's called
slightly different things in different
fields
it's the idea of completions
um
and
it's the idea that
uh
more or less when you have a maybe i
shouldn't get too deeply technical about
this but when you have sort of a branch
you can just sort of uh you you know
both things came from the same thing and
so you can consider them equal and you
can add that lemma um that critical pair
lemma as it's called to your collection
of things that you're using to do this
proof
and it turns out that
in some
uh that if you can add enough critical
parallels you can set it up so that your
theorem approval will never get lost in
this giant graph you'll always be able
to get back to the right place and get
to the theorem you want
um but the question then it becomes sort
of a black magic of adding the right
critical pair lemmas and there are
various strategies there's one called
unfailing completion which is a
particular strategy for dealing with
these things
zooming out a little bit
um there are
automated fear improving is a story of a
whole bunch of different tricks that
were invented
for
just sort of taking the theorems that
people might realistically want to prove
and being able to find ways to get those
things proved more efficiently than you
might i should say again that the at a
general level given a collection of
axioms that are reasonably rich axioms
like the accidents in arithmetic for
example we know from girdle's theorem
from 1931 that in principle there are
proofs that are arbitrarily long that is
this question of did your theorem prove
it get lost in the wilderness
that's it's very hard to say oh you've
been wandering around for too long it's
never going to work
you can't say that girdle's theorem
tells you that in general you won't be
able to say that you can be wandering in
the wilderness for a really really long
time and eventually you reach the
theorem that you were trying to get to
and i've certainly had many examples
even you know just outrageously long
times that you're sort of wandering in
that wilderness and you eventually come
back to essentially the theorem you want
so there's no upper bound on that and
the history of theorem improving
automated theorem proving has really
been a history of kind of
trying to do sort of black magic around
uh not getting lost in the wilderness
and you know there are a lot of
different techniques there's resolution
they're improving there's uh oh there
are things like paramodulation there's
uh just all these different names it is
a pretty obscure field
and the the things that uh you know
and i would say that that starting from
the 1950s that started in the 1960s
there started to be more theorem provers
a person called robinson whose first
name i now forget alan robinson i think
who was a a big a big sort of figure in
that in that whole development
um
a bunch of other people
the
it's a it's a funny field because it's a
field that's not really part of computer
science as most people think of computer
science it's definitely not part of math
as most people think of math
it's it's not really part of logic it's
sort of been a separate free-floating
field that's been pursued um in europe
and some places in the us
it's a very spotty kind of thing and
there have emerged a limited number
of of of decently developed automated
theorem proving systems
um i will say that back in year 2000
um i was interested in actually using
automate theorem proving to try and find
the simplest axiom system for boolean
algebra
and so i was using all these different
systems that existed
they were all babysitter only use
basically um if you were a sort of
this had been kind of the story i would
say in well it had been the story many
years earlier in computer algebra
before things that i tried to do it was
something where people didn't use
computer algebra very much this i'm
talking 1970s and so on because
the people who had developed the systems
had done it as a research project and so
on maybe they wanted to use it
themselves in some cases and they could
babysit it through to get to reasonable
answers but most of the people sort of
in the consumer world so to speak like
your average physicist or something like
that it's like it was just the creature
was just too unruly and they just
couldn't kind of you know they they
couldn't do the babysitting i think i
myself ended up being rather unusual in
the because i knew enough about
computers and maybe i just was
was young and eager enough for something
i did use these systems even though
they would split out things that
required significant babysitting and so
on that was for computer algebra back in
the late 1970s and you know the way that
story ended was that
um
the
uh you know i was interested in using
those systems on a sort of larger scale
and so on and this was 1979 and i was
encouraging people who worked on these
things you know you can do a lot better
than you've done so far you know build
another version of the system and
they're like oh no we don't want to do
that and so that's what caused me to
build smp
um and uh you know one of his use cases
with computer algebra and then later on
build mathematica and so on and uh
so in a sense i what i tried to do was
to take what had been a babysitting
required kind of area and turn it into
something that could be routinely used
by people sort of without babysitting
so now zooming forward many years to
2000 automated theorem proving was in
the same state it was a field where
it was usable with babysitting but not
really without
and so then i had this this actual
problem that i wanted to solve with
right there in berlin so i managed to
solve it
using uh
you know i tried several different
systems eventually ended up using one
written by a couple of austrian graduate
students who walled my the system it's
called worldmeister a master of trees
trees are sort of the the thing that
you're you're exploring in this giant
forest of different paths and so on in
any case the um
so i was able to to find this results
about the simplest taxing system for
bullying algebra which people looked for
uh for a long time in fact there was one
person kero meredith who spent decades
trying to whittle down the different the
level the size of that axiom and got
nowhere near the actual minimum size
which i was able to find by
computational search
but to my knowledge
even now 20 years later
the uh
that 20 22 years later
that result of mine from 2000 is the
only unexpected result ever found by
automated theorem building
all other results found by automated
theorem proving the things people sort
of already knew were true
and automated theorem proving is helping
to fill in some details
now i will say that the proof that i
made
for
by automatically for this simplest
action system for boolean algebra in 22
years nobody has understood this proof
certainly including me there's a person
named norm mcgill who was one of the
authors well the primary author
of a system called metamath which is a
proof assistant system and actually
towards the end of last the fall of last
year
he
was making a big effort to actually
understand the proof of this bullying
algebra accident of mine
and um
uh
wrote the email that he was making
progress and then unfortunately he died
um
i think december of last year sadly um
and so
that um uh so
and i'm not even sure i know that the
full extent of the progress he had made
but that's uh you know he said he was
making progress that's the first person
who's told me they're actually making
progress on understanding this proof
so that kind of tells you something
right there
that um
the uh
you get an automated proof and it's
absolutely incomprehensible to humans
it was
found it was a path from here to there
to here to there and you look at these
these
lemmas that the automated theorem
improver produced and it's like i have
no idea why this is true i don't know
how to talk about it
when you make a human proof
part of the point is to make a narrative
well the main point is really to make a
narrative that explains to another human
why the thing you're claiming is true is
actually true and so it's really a story
of creating that human narrative and
what the machine generates
is something that
doesn't have any reason to have a human
narrative at all
now having said that this this thing
about generating understandable proofs
the one place where i can say this is
done in a pretty industrial scale isn't
well from alpha in the step-by-step
system of ortho alpha we are uh people
are you know solving their math
homeworks or whatever
and
we are giving them a step-by-step
version of that solution that is
generated using all kinds of heuristics
to try and make something that you know
fits into those pesky humans and the
ways that they understand things it's
certainly not the way the machine
understands how to do it but it's the
way humans understand how to do it
so
in any case that that um
uh
in
in sort of automated theorem proving the
thing you get out is like yes you can
prove it's true unless you can convince
yourself it's true but it is not useful
as a narrative proof
now historically okay
so a little bit more on the theorem
proving so there's mathematical
automated theorem proving
that's a thing
i would say that has never become very
popular we have tried but i was
literally just in a meeting right before
this working on some uh live stream
meeting actually um working on some
details of our their improver
for for language um i would say we are
beginning to get to the point where we
are successfully consumerizing automated
theorem proving as a component of other
kinds of things that people want to do
um but it's only only just about getting
there mostly it's not something of great
math
interest
now there's another branch which is the
verification of things like protocols
and
there have been a whole series of
approvers
z3 prover i think that there are various
kinds of approvers
that were created primarily for the
purpose of validating computer code and
the um
uh and being able to check various
properties of programs
and there has been a branch of automated
theorem proving that i would say has
been quite successful which is tools to
validate things like oh there is no way
that this array can ever have uh be
written out of bounds or something
things that you can start to do to check
programs written particularly in
low-level languages
where you can say you know because some
some higher level language is like well
from language you you couldn't scribble
on memory outside where you're supposed
to scribble because you just don't have
direct access that's that's many layers
down in the kind of stack of of levels
of of abstraction um so unless there's a
bug in our code you can't just go and
scribble on memory somewhere else
whereas if you're using a language like
c you can just take your pointer and
just say add 75 to it and you'll be
pointing at a piece of memory that is
nowhere near where where where you've
actually set things up and you can just
start writing to that piece of memory
and your program might go nuts if you
did that and so on um but so one of the
places where automated theorem improving
has been quite successful is in making
tools for doing sort of automated
validation of some kinds of computer
operations it's also been somewhat
successful in protocol verification um
although i do remember
the um
many years ago now and i i think this
story i i i would i would say take this
story with a with a grain of salt it
it's it might have some apocryphal
elements to it but um the basic story
was there was a a fighter plane british
fighter plane i think
maybe french but i think british um
that
was very proudly said that all of its
flight logic
had been automatically verified it was
uh you know uh sort of
confirmed correct then the plane for the
first time flies across the equator and
turns upside down
um
so that's an example of
uh you know when people say people talk
about program verification
and what do you mean by program
verification what's the program supposed
to do
oh they say we've got a specification of
what the program does
well what language is that specification
written in oh it's basically another
language so essentially what you're
saying is you've got a program and
you're trying to verify it by having
written another program
and
it doesn't really help you very much
because that other program which would
be some program that has some
specification of all kinds of results
that must be true about the plane that
didn't know about i don't know what it
was sensing coriolis forces or gps
coordinates or something i think it was
before gps so so whatever it was um but
uh so you know it doesn't help you to
have the verifying program also written
in a language also with its own bugs
what you can do is to say there is a
property that i want to be true like i
can never
access a piece of memory that i can
never
you know read a piece of memory that i
didn't write to first or something like
that you can have certain properties
like that and you can verify those and
that's been a fairly successful branch
of of sort of some level of automated
theorem proven
now there's there's a yet another branch
i'm afraid this is a messy history uh
this isn't this isn't one of these
things where it went one step two steps
three steps it's a 70-year history where
it's been kind of a small area that's
that's had little steps in one one way
or another um but um hasn't been a very
coherent story
um
i will say that there are
uh you know another piece of that story
is that uh term rewriting systems
um that is you have uh you rewrite this
to that you rewrite this to that and so
on and it's very much like automated
theorem proving you're saying can you
find a series of rewritings that will
get me from here to there or does this
series of rewritings terminate those
kinds of things there's been kind of a
whole world of people with competitions
about term rewriting where there are
sort of systems that are sort of like
automated theorem proverbs and some of
them are the same as automate their
improvers some are a little bit
different that are trying to do those
kinds of things term rewriting is
something where well it sort of has
applications to program verification
maybe it has mathematic
applications to mathematical theorem
proving but it's sort of its own field
and its own kind of strangely
encapsulated kind of interesting field
that doesn't really quite have a place
anywhere
so
the other game in town is proof
assistance
those really came on the scene
i would say
well okay they have a long history
there's a person called nicholas de
bruyne
uh
who um
uh d e space
b r u i
j n
uh dutch chap
who worked most of most of his life at
uh phillips i believe
um
i believe that's right
uh
maybe i'm slightly wrong about that
maybe he was at a university in the
netherlands i'm not sure
but anyway um de bruyne
uh
was
did a whole variety of things but one of
the things he did was he had a project
called automath
and this was in the late 50s early 60s i
believe
and the idea of auto math
was to make what today will be called
the proof assistant system there's a
little bit muddled between it's sort of
a way of representing mathematical
proofs it's sort of an automated theorem
proving system but more i think on the
direction of representing mathematical
proofs
i don't know how well it got implemented
i'm not sure it ever got implemented
most of the things i've seen are sort of
theoretical documents about it and i
don't believe i've ever
uh is that true have i ever talked to
anybody who actually was involved with
that project yes i'm sure i have but um
i don't think i've managed to drill into
that history very well
um
there were other projects there was a
thing called mizar m-i-z-a
and like the star m-i-c-a-r
um that was a project to make
a um
uh
it went along with a journal of
formalized mathematics
and it
was um
a uh
it was an attempt to curate
essentially to to have a language for
mathematical theorems to collect a lot
of mathematical theorems to be able to
publish those mathematical theorems in a
formalized way this is something from
the
1960s i think primarily
there's even other pieces to this this
is a complicated history and and i don't
think i i you know i don't know it
perfectly actually i know i probably
know most of the pieces of it i've never
really put this history properly
together okay there's another piece
um
which i believe
was also connected to brower
uh that personal interest in the
foundations of mathematics and the
netherlands
um
and there was a person called hans
freudenthal
uh who i think was a student at browers
who was a person who
ended up trying to make sort of a
formalized representation of the
mathematical process
uh he invented a thing called lin cause
that he called the um
uh
the language's cosmic intercourse it was
intended to be a language for
communicating with extraterrestrials
using set theory and it's kind of a
bizarre exercise of it's very weird
thing
but
it
um that was all somehow connected to the
de bruyne auto math project but these
were these were sort of theoretical
pushes to say can we make a formalized
notation
for things like mathematical proofs by
the way there's sort of a history to
that in the sense that
um whitehead and russell in that
principia mathematica from 1910
they were trying to sort of formalize
mathematics as based on logic to derive
mathematics from logic that was an idea
that originally had come from gottlob
fraga
in the 1870s 1880s
um that
went through a guiseppe piano around
1890s 1900
uh piano had this thing called
interlingua which was a kind of math
representation language um
that uh uh and he also had his piano
actions and so on all of these things
were mostly ways of stating mathematics
but they also had ways of essentially
presenting proofs using some kind of
formalized language i think that kind of
flowed into eventually things like
automath
now
the actual automated theorem proving
systems
um i was uh were
uh i think they were
not as related to that as one might
think
they more came out of so the the davis
putnam thing
was
uh something that was developed on
the
oh gosh that was developed i think
uh some work was done on the
john von neumann's computer at the
institute for advanced study um a very
early computer uh some work i think was
done on the university of illinois
computer
what was it the iliac
um
and so very early computers this idea of
being able to do sort of logic theorem
proving was a very early idea in in
electronic computers um i think people
had associated uh perhaps the reason for
that was
that
um the whole sort of computers were seen
as being like sort of glorified
switching networks
and following
uh for example claude shannon's early
work
on sort of the relationship between
boolean algebra and switching networks
people were sort of like well these
things it's kind of boolean algebra is
an obvious target for these things we're
making that are kind of like boolean
algebra machines perhaps that was the
the thinking but but this idea of doing
sort of logical
uh
logic with machines was a very early
idea in in in computer history i mean
there had even been
well okay when computers were mechanical
when there was things like babbage's
difference engine in the in the 1830s
and so on
um
there was some
uh a chap called stanley jevons
who i think was primarily an economist
um
but he had a logic machine
that was again sort of a mechanical
device
that was a little bit in the tradition
of the difference engine again
attempting to resolve kind of logic
expressions in the same kind of way that
the difference engine was trying to
resolve trying to compute polynomials so
this is a messy history wow guys i'm i'm
sorry it's so messy um i would like to
be able to just tell you you know
beginning middle end to the story but i
think it has many many tentacles
um this idea of proof assistance where
you're kind of writing out a proof in a
formalized way and then a computer is
checking your proof
um i think auto math had that idea um i
think there were
uh a series of of different kinds of
small-scale systems there was it was
another piece of the story which is a
thing called the qed manifesto which was
an attempt to sort of define a an effort
to do formalized mathematics that must
have been in the
1980s 90s maybe it was not a success
um i think it partly was related to this
mizar system and so on
anyway
long story so so then
this idea of proof assistance
uh
one of the places that became somewhat
popular is mathematicians including some
well-known mathematicians who were
frustrated because they had developed
very long proofs and nobody believed
that
so this happened to um tom hales
a person who uh worked on actually used
mathematica a whole bunch
to um to prove the kepler conjecture the
the kepler conjecture says that if you
if you stacks if you pack spheres
together the closest packing you can get
is this one that people use in grocery
stores to pack spherical fruit um just
like it was known from uh
oh
let's see back in the
1600s or 1700s it was known that if you
have just discs
and you try and pack them as densely as
possible the hexagonal packing of discs
is the densest possible packing but the
three-dimensional analog of that was not
known and it had been sort of an open
problem for a long time and tom hales
used uh a bunch of mathematica analysis
and a bunch of sort of arbitrary
precision arithmetic and being able to
find bounds on inequalities and so on
and produce this big proof
of
uh the
of of the capital conjecture and people
was like oh this is a 300 page paper
nobody can read it how do we know it's
right why aren't the errors in it and he
got very frustrated and he decided to
mount an effort to really make an
automated make a a proof assistant proof
of that conjecture where you can really
validate every step precisely i think it
took him about a decade and sadly i'm
not sure anybody cared
um it's uh
you know it's a magnificent thing to do
and and you're you can be you know it
helps you to make
sure of it better for yourself now
another person uh named vervotsky
um
was was somebody a sort of high-end pure
mathematician
who uh got interested in proof assistant
systems
and
um uh uh the
and uh and really
um i think he had so some error he'd
found or other people had found in some
some piece of work he'd done he sort of
got convinced if it can be done with a
proof assistant and i can be sure it's
right
i i don't know the precise relationship
i mean i certainly talked to vervodsky
and i'm trying to remember whether i
know from that history
uh
was very much involved in the creation
of homotopy type theory which is kind of
a a way of redoing the foundations of
the way you think about mathematics to
be a little bit more like the sort of
formalized way it would work in a proof
of system and i'm not sure which came
first homotopic type theory or
vervodsky's interest in proof assistant
systems i think it was probably proof of
assistance but i'm not certain but there
have been these various efforts and
there are a number of people now who are
sort of big promoters of of um the idea
of proof assistance systems i mean we've
done a bunch of work with lean
uh which is a proof assistant system
there's there's [ __ ] there's some uh
well there's there's metamath which
we've done a lot with
um uh that's not metamath is a little
bit of a
of a slightly different community each
one of these each one of these proof
assistant systems has a certain kind of
community associated with it
and they're somewhat disjoint i mean
lean is came out of microsoft and came
out of uh essentially validation for
things like programs
but then has been sort of adopted by
mathematicians but it came out of the
world of um
sort of automated program verification
um and uh particularly for very
practical purposes like compiler uh
enhancement and so on uh slightly
different from the traditions that some
of these other systems have come out of
i mean there are there are other ones um
uh
oh my gosh what's the one from the
uh
thm qthm
um i'm i'm forgetting all of these names
um but they
many of these systems have slightly
different slightly different domains
they operate on
and so on and slightly
at this point one of the things that's
happened is there are quite large
libraries of around 40 000 theorems
that have been collected in formalized
form and that exists that between
between thirty thousand and a hundred
thousand theorems these different
systems the biggest ones i think are
lean [ __ ] metamath has a pretty big one
um and so on
um
and uh
i'm i'm forgetting i i feel terrible
here because i'm forgetting the names of
some of these systems and we had a
lovely conference that we we organized a
few years ago which collected pretty
much all of the the creators of um of
these major systems
and um uh i'm i'm uh like super
embarrassed that i can't remember all of
their names immediately but um uh in any
case the um
uh oh yes that's whole light that's
another one hol but each of these
systems has a slightly different way of
representing its mathematical axiom set
up and and and different sort of
interface for operating and different
slightly different characteristics
um but in any case the the the kind of
the vision that some people have is the
mathematician of the future will just be
kind of putting things into a proof
assistant system and at the end it will
say success
you successfully managed to prove the
theorem you thought you were proving
i think that's a rather desiccated view
of mathematics
that particularly in view of the things
that i've studied recently about the
physicalization mathematics seems like a
wrong idealization of what mathematics
is about
um and i think
the
uh
it's something where you know that very
proceduralized you know just fit all the
pieces together and then you will know
you have a correct theorem uh doesn't i
you know that has its place
but
in terms of
um sort of the conceptual discovery in
mathematics
i'm not sure how useful that is
um i think vastly more useful
is the actual ability to compute things
in mathematics let me let me mention
another uh story i'm sorry this is a bit
bit a bit ragged here
but um
uh
you know when people like whitehead and
russell
tried to formalize mathematics hilbert
also
they tried to make a sort of formalized
representation of mathematics the
question was what did they think
mathematics was
they thought mathematics was all about
proving things from axioms a little bit
like how euclid had kind of set it up
but how hilbert had really emphasized
mathematics the workflow of mathematics
well so when people started thinking
about how are we going to use computers
to do mathematics
some of this early activity around
theorem proving was probably
let's take that workflow model of
mathematics that had existed in
whitehead and russell and so on and
let's put that on computers and that
workflow was doing proofs
well turns out the thing that was sort
of the meta discovery in a sense i made
was that turns out there's a lot more
interest and a lot more practicality to
doing computations in mathematics than
doing proofs in mathematics so in
building mathematica and more from
language and so on it's all about just
compute things in mathematics
now in a sense some of the things we're
computing are proofs
like for example we say
you know use the reduced function in
welfare language does this set of
equations have a solution answer no
okay
that could be thought of as the result
of a proof that the equations have no
solution
but it's not packaged as a proof
activity it's packaged as a answer the
question do these equations have a
solution so the sort of meta discovery
of i suppose mine in the 1980s was the
formalization of mathematics to be
useful is vastly more about just
computing things than it is about
formalizing proofs that was an incorrect
formalization of what mathematics is
about and i actually think that even
more strongly now that i've worked on
this physicalization of meta mathematics
but now the next question is
is the correct formalization of what
mathematicians do the sort of proof of
system formalization and i don't think
it is i think those that has a place
it probably has a place if anything more
so on the computer science side than it
does on the mathematics side i mean for
example if you look at the compiler for
language that we've been building for
many years but it's making wonderful
progress now
it has to prove a lot of theorems it has
to say
does this loop that is defined by this
nest list and fold list and so on could
the result of this ever be anything
other than a list could it ever be or
you know could it ever be anything other
than a two-dimensional list let's say oh
whoops there's an exception to that
theorem it could be a null list
so we effectively have to do theorem
proving within the compiler to be able
to know kind of uh what what the
structure of the results will be so
that's a very practical application and
i happen to believe
that we will end up with some proof
assistant-like stuff
where humans are essentially hinting
what might be true about this the data
that they have see this is a sort of a
competition because we've got on the one
hand
uh
just compute to the answer
on the other hand we've got
the automatically prove a theorem and on
the other hand we've got
it's too hard to automatically prove the
theorem the human has to guide it and
specify what they think the theorem is
and the computer will check it
okay thrown into this is then machine
learning and then there's a question
well could you
get sort of machine learning to
intermediate between proof assistance
and automated theorem improving that is
for example have a proof assistant but
it isn't a human who's specifying what
the proof is supposed to be it's some
machine learning system right now that
doesn't look super promising i would say
there are some cool examples
but mostly what that's doing is i
mentioned that on already they're
improving the big thing is not getting
lost in the wilderness
and the question is can you use uh
machine learning to guess whether it's
the left path or the right path that you
should take and it seems to be slightly
successful at doing that i wouldn't say
it's dramatic yet but it's at least
slightly successful at doing that maybe
um
it's some but you know the the real
heavy lifting of automated theorem
proving doesn't seem to be helped by
that it's not like you can
expect the neural nets to just learn oh
that this hundred step proof
you know i'm just gonna create this
hundred step proof it's just not gonna
happen that way
maybe you're at a branch point and you
can say okay is it worth you know i've
got i'm going to run one computation is
it worth trying that one rather than
that one by the way that's very similar
to what we do a lot in meta algorithms
and more from language where we might
have a hundred different ways to do a
computation and we're using essentially
machine learning to decide which way to
try to do it you know we're solving a
differential equation and we can tell
whether we're getting the right answer
um or even simplifying an expression
we're starting to use this for that you
simplify an expression you know the
transformations you're doing will always
get you correct answers the question is
how small can you get the simplified
expression and you can use machine
learning to guess kind of which branch
you should take in trying to simplify
the expression oh is it a good idea to
do trigonometric things or is it a good
idea to try and do this other thing you
can tell whether you got it right but
it's something where it's not obvious uh
there's no sort of standard algorithm
that says oh you should try you know
expanding out the trigonometric function
zero oh you should try sort of uh
compressing the square roots here
so uh anyway that that's um
now i mean dennis has asked here would
would there be an error where computers
proof theorems and mathematicians
interpret them i don't think like that
what there is is experimental
mathematics
what there is
is just go out into the mathematical
universe effectively and go find what's
true
and then figure out why it's true
that's a big thing to do
that's something that mathematicians
many
mathematicians have secretly done those
kinds of things
you know gauss riemann they secretly did
that looking at the distribution of
primes but what they published and what
they talked about was oh we've proved
this theorem about the distribution of
time primes secretly they'd done a
numerical experiment effectively to find
out what was likely to be true
kind of probably the master of those
things with ramanujan in the 1910s um
doing uh coming up with these amazing
sort of number theoretical statements
uh like e to the pi square root of a
hundred and
[Music]
137 no oh 192. am i remember i forget
what the square root is e to the pi
square root of something some three
digit number
is extremely close to an integer that's
something ramu jan discovered
and uh you might have said well
you know so that was
discovered in in that case by human
calculator but in modern times that
would be discovered by a computer and
then the big question is so what
and ramanujan turned that into a huge
bunch of mathematics including for a
long time the best algorithm for
computing pi accurately and so on but
this is this whole question about you
find what's true out there in the kind
of mathematical universe and then you
say well why is that true can i build a
kind of narrative structure around that
one of the things that we realized
recently
is that well the thing i've done a lot
is kind of going out into the
computational universe of possible
programs and just finding what can
happen out there
and
that's kind of like exploring alien
intelligence in a sense
it's something where out there in the
computational universe
there are rules that you can easily
generate or write down
that are just completely unconnected to
anything we humans have thought about
so i view it as being when i talk about
the rouliad and rulial space and so on
in a sense
uh we can do sort of exploration
of uh ordinary physical space we can
also do exploration of rule space
um and in a sense what we're doing when
we kind of just do that random computer
experiment we're jumping out somewhere
in rural space and trying to find out
what's going on there
and there's no reason to think that
there's a narrative story that connects
that to things we already knew so in a
sense when you say well mathematicians
build well mathematicians just be
presented with results and then told to
interpret them the problem with that is
the interpretation may not be a
narrative that mathematicians are even
close to mathematicians have been sort
of building out this narrative that's
now about three or four million theorems
in the in the literature of human
mathematics that's a kind of a whole
narrative of how things work
but if you just jump out there into sort
of mathematical experimental
mathematical space you can jump
somewhere that's far away from any
narrative that exists
and so this idea that you can then sort
of have mathematicians go interpret
those things that's a really tough thing
to do because it's like what i was
mentioning with cellular automata and so
on you're jumping into this part of the
computational universe where math is far
away it doesn't really help you very
much
um and so you end up having to build
sort of in in the words of things i've
done a new kind of science to think
about how to deal with things where
you've just jumped off into a random
place in the computational universe and
you see phenomena like computational
reducibility and so on
anyway so a long and rather shaggy
answer to that that question
um
so i should probably wrap up soon
but um
uh okay it's a question from stove here
okay
uh interesting question will be can you
flip around automated theorem proving
algorithms to figure out why black box
neural nets do what they do
uh
no
basically
i i don't think so because
both neural nets and automated theorem
proven are deeply non-human
and
if you want to know why neural net does
what it does
well
uh you know for example in in version
13.1 of orphan language which is about
to come out
uh we have
some
some more tools
to
find out what the impact of particular
features is for a neural net so at least
you can answer the question you know oh
my credit was denied somewhere you know
what was the most important feature that
caused that to happen
um that you can get some information
about
by basically looking at the kind of the
the the differentiable structure of the
neural net and saying well if we change
this you know what's the thing that
mattered most in terms of changing it
but that's a that's sort of a a a very
simple kind of human narrative type
explanation of the thing that mattered
was this if you ask the bigger picture
of how do you explain what the neural
net is doing
that's something for which
we it's just a very non-human thing it's
kind of an alien intelligence
and
what we could say as well the neural net
noticed that
uh
in this kind of image you could see oh
yeah these stripes that go this way in
that way and so that's the way that it
did this distinction between this type
of image and that type of image now in
the world of the future we might learn
there's a word we should add to our
language which is you know
vertical blobs and um horizontal stripes
let's say
and that that word should be
it's a
it's a as a
i don't know it's a um
horror striper or something or who knows
what it is a a horror a a blob o stripe
um
and uh
uh you know that oh yes that looks very
blobbo stripy and eventually we get that
word in our language and we start to
associate all those things with it and
then when we look at the neural nets we
can say well it's just testing for the
blob oh stripery of this image
um and and then then that gives us a
piece of human understandability there
but without that kind of socialization
of these concepts we don't get to have
kind of a human
language
described narrative for what's going on
so i don't think there's i think those
are those are two different technologies
they're improving and neural nets they
both have this kind of alien
intelligence character to them they're
actually two of the
the
sort of a little bit the bigger i mean i
suppose the other the other type of
alien intelligence is the kind of thing
that's deeply built into language all
over the place which is just algorithms
for doing things where gosh how could
you figure out this or that thing well
it turns out there's this algorithm for
doing that
so
um
let's see
parker is commenting on
will
will general
agi
artificial general intelligence but the
future of automation
or will it be a symbolic language like
wolverine language
oh that's such a long story i'm i mean
the um
uh maybe i shouldn't do that now
that's a very interesting question um
the uh i would not have spent 40 years
working on the computational language
that i've spent 40 years working on if i
believed that it was the wrong approach
um i think
there is this whole question of
do you
if you want to make a plane do you
imitate the feathers of a bird or do you
try to make this thing out of aluminum
that uh you know goes through the air
rapidly so to speak
that's that's part of the dichotomy
in you know how do you make a thing that
does useful aish stuff
do you imitate the details of of human
intelligence or do you build something
that achieves the objectives but by
different methods so to speak
and i think the key thing
is
so you have this thing it's sitting on
your desk it's a general intelligence
whatever what do you want it to do
you could like
you could talk to it in in
in sort of ordinary language and yeah we
might be able to do some things based on
that but in the end the way you're truly
going to get leverage
from sort of the the computational side
of things is by having a more
streamlined way to represent
computational thoughts and that's kind
of the whole idea of our computational
language is to be able to represent
computational thoughts
in
a
in a kind of structured notation
you know the big analogy that i like to
give us to mathematical notation uh
before one had mathematical notation it
was hard to express mathematical
thoughts they had to be expressed with
words and
and so on and then one had this sort of
streamlined notation
and it's sort of the same thing you you
can either talk to your ai and try and
say well i want you to do this and oh
well there's this piece in that piece
and that piece or you can do something
which is a real jump above that and say
here's this thing written in
computational language
now the big point is that computational
language is intended to be a bridge to
human thinking it's a bridge between the
computational universe and human
thinking and you could say well
why don't you just i mean the point is
there's great power in the computational
universe
most of which we humans do not care
about most of those you know complicated
programs that run in this or that way
maybe
you know a thousand years from now sort
of the
the whatever the meta descendants of us
are
will care about that weird kind of
computation that we never cared about
because it will turn out that's really
important
for the kind of social pecking order of
people who are making derived you know
infinitely derived pieces of
intellectual property that are you know
that represent a combination of you know
art and food or something and things
that we just have no
no conception of um and uh you know then
those things that we have thought oh
that's just a random piece of
computation that we don't really care
what it does will become very central to
um uh to the way that people think about
things and you know we can see that over
the course of history that plenty of
things that we now
uh are you know focused on you know
uh
the you know ratings rankings for this
or that thing
these things were things that just
didn't really you know you would have
explained that to somebody a thousand
years ago and they would have kind of
looked at you blankly why do you care
what how does that connect into anything
you're doing
so i mean i think that the um
uh this
the thing that we get to do in this time
in history is actually start to mine the
computational universe really make use
of the power of of computation
and sort of my personal goal
in in over the course of the last four
decades or so has been to provide um
the um
uh
the um
uh to to um uh provide
that sort of way of of of letting us
humans
make use of
the the power of the computational
universe i mean it's kind of like you
could say well
uh you know back before people
understood how to mine metals out of the
ground and it was just you know that
looks like a piece of rock oh well when
you heat it up you do this and that you
can extract iron from it um that's a um
we're at the stage where we've got the
rocks so to speak in the computational
universe and we have to build the mining
equipment and you know i've spent a
large part of my life trying to build
some of that mining equipment
it's another sort of analogy to that
is you know how do people express
themselves
well you know we as a species learnt a
couple hundred thousand years ago
whenever it was how to you know speak in
languages
um
uh you know
less time ago than that maybe four
thousand years ago or something we
started to learn how to write these
things and then that became a widespread
capability you know maybe 500 years ago
now and i think that this process of we
can express ourselves
in language in written language
and we will be able to express ourselves
in computational language and that's
something that will gradually come just
like at least some part of the
population is able to express itself
somewhat in mathematical language that's
a phenomenon from the last 400 years or
so
um
let's see just one more thing perhaps
here uh
um
richard comments i think the
computational mathematics system of the
future will be generating new languages
new notations new proofs new theorems
and new conjectures
uh the problem is to have a system that
doesn't have to also generate new humans
because you know the weak link here is
humans learning stuff i mean i could say
that about the things i've done in my
life
you know i've invented lots of stuff
uh you know i think it's really cool and
some
set of people understand it but there's
an awful lot of humans who would be able
to do you know have an awful lot of
superpowers if they understood it but
they don't
and there's kind of this weak link of
how do you get the humans to the point
where they understand these new xyz
things and that's something that happens
sort of societally as some slow
socialized process
um and it's something where typically
small numbers of humans go out and you
know they're the they're the the uh the
pioneers who go and understand things
before everybody else i mean i've i've
taken to sometimes referring to some of
the technology we've built as artifacts
from the future you know it's the sort
of small band of pioneers that can go
and and grab these things from the
distant future even when sort of the
weak link is uh kind of having the mass
of people really understand that stuff
now you know as a designer of languages
my
my it's a little different than than can
happen with nature and so on because
it's kind of my job to make it as easy
as possible make that on-ramp as as
shallow as possible
and you know we've done a lot
particularly in recent times with the
code assistance technology and so on to
try and achieve that to try and make it
kind of uh you know as easy as possible
but there are concepts and those
concepts represent a different way of
thinking about things and it's
challenging for people to have different
ways of thinking about things i would
say that that merely enumerating a whole
boatload of new theorems
is not particularly useful i mean it's
easy to do that and people will say why
do we care and then you have to say well
you care because well there's this
narrative now okay so one thing richard
might be referring to
is that
you know one could imagine
a system that really had sussed out the
humans
and it said okay humans
you know much like our step-by-step
system and wolfman alpha does okay
humans i know what to feed you the next
thing you should be thinking about is
acts you know i the computer
the sort of computational language i can
jump
way out in real space i can go find
these things that are amazing kinds of
things that i could go in mine but you
humans you don't care about that yet
it'll be 500 more years before you guys
care about that
so i suppose i can imagine maybe that
the thing to think about is you know can
you build a system which says for us
humans in the next 10 years
what you know what might you care about
in the next 10 years not what's true out
there altogether because that's way too
far away that's alien intelligence
that's that's um you know you're not
going to understand that yet
um and so that's that's sort of a
question now i have to say i've been
interested in making systems that do
with things a little bit like this
so for example one of my favorite kinds
of potential applications is code
debugging
and you run a piece of code it gets an
answer that you think is wrong
you say to the system why is it wrong
you know you say i expected seven you
gave me 18. why why did that happen
and so then the question is is it
possible to give an explanation for why
you've got 18 rather than seven that a
human can understand
just saying will you run the codename
gives 18 that doesn't tell you anything
that's that's not useful that's like the
proof assistant system just saying blump
there's a there's a there's a big um uh
you know here's the big proof that you
could in principle run to validate
things
but in any case the the you know the
question is could the machine build a
narrative that humans can understand uh
interesting question
um i think
you know maybe the answer is yes i think
that's not something that we have seen
i mean i suppose that that's a little
bit analogous okay let's talk about user
experience design the vast majority of
user experience design is done by humans
it's very little of it it's done
automatically this is in a sense a
perhaps more sophisticated version of
user experience design you might think
that i did think 20 years ago i thought
web page layout would be largely
automated that is if somebody says you'd
say i have a web page i've got a bunch
of things i want to put on this page i
want to emphasize this i want to
de-emphasize this i want people's flow
to be this and that the other you have
some kind of little language that
describes your objectives for the web
page and then the thing gets laid out
automatically um i mean i suppose at a
very low level that's what's happening
in css and responsive design but very
very low level there it's not kind of
the the sort of high level cognitive
description but i think one of the
problems with that is that even the
description language of what's important
to layout where on the page is not an
easy thing to specify and by the time
you've specified that you might as well
just laid out the page
um
let's see so
yeah i think um
it's very interesting question really
whether whether
okay so this question of whether
an ai can learn enough about us humans
to help us think
in a
in a kind of a this kind of narrative
thinking path
for sure
ais and quotes dramatically help us
think i mean i use welfare language for
hours every day helping me think
and
but you would say but that's not a you
know that's not an agi type thing that's
just
you know a computer
and you're right but it certainly is a
is a great thinking prosthesis so to
speak of uh you know it lets me it lets
me figure out a lot more things than i
could possibly ever figure out myself
but it figures them out in this very
non-human way in many many respects i
can then understand that in a human way
but what it's doing is to figure things
out in a very very non-human way
and i think um
um
let's see alistair comments ai is an
effort to create electronic learning not
human thinking you know one of the
things i find interesting in terms of
the sort of historical arc i remember
when i was a kid
so we're now talking
55 years ago or something that's
probably from that time um you know i
remember i had a book
about the future or something
and
one of the kind of sort of the the
the the great pages of the book was the
teaching machines of the future
and the idea was uh this will be the way
people learn things is they'll just be
fed stuff by a teaching machine
well
it didn't happen that way
and uh you know we
we
uh
even adaptive learning
the idea of of um
for example having uh you know you you
make the test slightly more difficult
you do this and the other
simple versions of that have been done
and work fine and are readily in
production
attempts to make that super fancy have
not been very successful
there are hacks relevant to humans like
space repetition and so on where you say
you know do this do it again with a
different uh frequency and so on and and
that that is a hack that helps us
uh that people have found out helps with
human memorization
but this idea that there will be sort of
the teaching machine that is sort of
perfectly adapted that understands us
humans well enough to know exactly what
to say next well it hasn't happened yet
um and it's uh you know i i kind of
wonder
one of the things that's sort of a often
a joke of people who build computer
systems is
you tell the humans the computer system
is learning from you humans you know
just do things in this and that way the
computer system will learn
okay turns out that's not what really
happens the human learns the human
learns this works this doesn't work and
the human modifies their behavior and
actually the computer system doesn't
have to learn anything just telling the
human the computer system is going to
learn
might be enough to get the human to
learn and so you never have to have the
computer system learn i think it's the
same sort of question with agi and
computational language and so on is at
some point the humans just learn to
write computational language and then
this whole oh you need this sort of agi
human-like feathered
intelligence in the middle becomes not a
thing i mean the thing i really noticed
long ago people were very focused on the
turing test you know this thing from
1950 of alan turing's of can you talk to
a machine and not know you're talking to
a machine rather than human
and people are very focused on you know
can we make that work etc etc etc and
you know would that be the way that we
automate things
but they missed user interfaces
because that turned out to be the way i
mean alan turing in 1950 didn't know
about graphical user interfaces and why
should he have done didn't foresee that
but the fact is that the vast majority
of interaction that we do with computers
and
and with automated systems involves some
kind of visual uh component and that's
something that just wasn't imagined in
this kind of channel that was thought
about where it's just you just talk to
it so to speak so i think that's a case
again where where the thing that is easy
for the computer becomes the thing that
humans find uh convenient to
and it wasn't the thing that was just
what was appropriate in the human to
human setting
um
let's see
uh
right alistair is commenting on
self-learning programs will not develop
human-like emotions it has no
physiological needs there's no need to
fear it can be replicated backed up
turned off and on i wonder about that
you know i was i was trying to write
something i hope i'll get to it in the
next little while
about what it's like to be a computer
because i was trying to understand
people say oh consciousness you'll never
be able to replicate that in some kind
of computer type enviro you know world
but what really does it feel like to
even be a computer of the current kind
we have
that you know you boot it up it runs for
days weeks months whatever
it it crashes again it has certain
memories during that that session that
operating system session
you know how does it feel to be that
computer if we try to
imagine that does the computer say you
know does the computer essentially have
the analog of fear you know don't plug
that thing into my you know usb port
something could go horribly wrong
or don't you know
and what will be kind of the correlate
of that
and uh you know it may have these kind
of responses which which as much as we
can
uh you know attribute fear to a dog or
something like this
we might be able to attribute it to a
computer i think that's that remains
something that's a little hard to to
disentangle even for the technology we
have today
um
all right i should wrap up here i've got
to go to some other things but um thanks
for lots of interesting questions and
comments
and uh
look forward to uh talking to you all
again
another day
thanks very much